next up let's take a look at actions or
those behaviors that result in rewards
and stem from the triggers that you sent
users here you'll want to optimize your
model to eliminate your users pain and
get them to interact with your app
thereby increasing their potential to
spend money ask yourself the following
questions where is the most challenging
action in your product why is it
challenging how can you test and improve
this action here's a hint analytics play
a huge role in finding answers that are
based on data take a minute and jot down
how you might use analytics to help
identify and eliminate these roadblocks